i got some good news
she sure does sherry shepherd isn't
leaving her role as guest co-host of the
wendy williams show anytime soon isn't
that fabulous as wendy williams
continues to take time to focus on her
health thesaurus tells e.t sherry is
taking over the show for now
okay let's do this
[Applause]
but don't worry the titular host is
expected to come back the source adds
the show remains optimistic that wendy
will return in the fall and we've got a
lot to talk about this news comes just
weeks after the talk show announced
wendy's hiatus will continue it's been
nearly five months since the tv
personality began her medical leave of
absence wendy i know you're watching
right now on behalf of myself the panel
your co-host we love you and can't wait
to have you back in that person
and despite being away wendy seems to be
in good spirits last month her son kevin
hunter jr shared this rare clip of his
mom treating herself to a meal in bed
[Music]
as for the new permanent guest host
sherry she's been battling health scares
of her own literary and i was i started
crying i started crying
because the doctor said that i needed to
have my appendix taken out like right
then and there in december the tv
personality returned to her guest host
duties just a day after undergoing an
emergency appendectomy i am a survivor
i'm from a chicago girl you can't hold
me down too long sherry detailed exactly
what happened leading up to her having
her appendix removed i'm walking through
the streets of new york city and it
literally it was this excruciating pain
in my abdomen literally they put me on
an iv
and uh then they took they gave me a cat
scan suzanne and they came back and they
said that i had appendicitis but the
view alum shared just how committed she
is to her hosting duties so i asked the
doctor i said could you guys do it on
friday the doctor said no so little and
i never do this i never do the celebrity
thing but i pulled my mask down and i
said do you know who i am i'm filling in
for wendy williams
i gotta do wendy williams
but the doctor said they said sherry if
your appendix birth they said that you
could die that's what they told me now
sherry hasn't been the only guest host
for the wendy williams show so it is
time for ask leah okay and michelle et
spoke with villains leah remini and
michelle visage who gushed about why
they love working on the show we have a
great time with wendy's crew and it's
again this is something that she builds
that we're just guests in and there are
other guest hosts and we love them all
and we support them all because you know
i say if you're a wendy fan then you're
going to support who's there to help her
show carry on right exactly and so she
comes back and obviously you guys are
naturals and pros you are not this is
not your first rodeo in the hosting game
but what made you say yes to stepping in
and filling in for wendy
well we thought it was gonna be fun for
starters yes and we've never you know
we've been best friends for a long time
and we wanted to do something together
so it was like this was like the perfect
thing
[Music]